Um, um, hello.
Um, hi.
Um, hello.
Wait, hold on, I'm moving.
I'm grabbing my mic and said, Oh, go ahead, Jinjama, itchama, hello.
Look, though.
P&D but I have video in the background so that you will still watch so that you will still you'll still be paying attention yeah hello everybody um I'm in a hotel room so there were many things that went wrong with this stream the first being that I'm in the hotel room.
And the second being that.
Oh my gosh.
What's it called?
The noise gate on this thing is crazy.
How does it sound?
Oh, okay.
Nevermind.
The GoXLR program does not work.
So I actually can't update anything.
So we're just gonna, I sound loud.
We're just gonna need, we're just gonna, we're just gonna, uh, we're just gonna do it.
I sound okay.
Yeah, that sounds fine.
Um.
What was I saying?
Oh, so I'm in the hotel room.
And, um, well, I was like, I'm going to test.
Okay, hold on.
Let me explain hotel struggles first.
Um, I was like, okay, I'm going to sign in to get free Wi-Fi.
And then they were like, oh, sorry, you can't log in right now.
We're working on it.
And I said, okay, cool, then I'll hotspot.
So I'm hotspotting and it might be bad.
Hopefully not bad, though.
And then, and then, um, and then there's one plug by the desk.
And I need a plug for my laptop and also for this USB hub that I bring with me.
So I need two plugs.
And because I cannot plug in both, I cannot also plug in my camera for me to move.
And so, I need two plugs.
And so, because of that, hotel Wi-Fi is always a gamba.
well it shouldn't be can't you plug your camera directly into your computer great question I cannot do that because I only have two USB slots and that's why I need the USB hub because I need to plug in my go XLR and I need to plug in my mouse and I need to plug in my phone USB USB USB
Osp.
Yeah, I'm Metal Gear thinking about guns.
So...
Can you put Family Guy clips in the corner?
No!
They're gonna take me out.
This is Family Guy!
Hold on.
How's the song go?
It seems today that all you see is violence and movies and sex online.
TV wait hold on commercial 1121 star but where are those good old-fashioned values on which we used to rely lucky there's a family guy lucky there's a man who can do all the things that make us laugh and cry he's a family guy
I'm like laying on the couch.
Not laying on the couch.
I'm sitting, but I threw my head back because I was laughing and I hit my head.
Good morning, USA.
I have a feeling that it's going to be a wonderful day.
That's the Superior Show.
I like American Dad way more than I like.
family guy, I think.
That's the superior show.
The sun in the sky has a smile on its face.
And a salute to the American race.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Oh, boy, I'm so young to say, Good morning, you are saying.
Boys, Oh yeah, shot B12.
Yeah.
I haven't watched American Down in so long, though.
Nailed it.
I know.
But, um...
Uh...
Yeah, so then, that's why I'm a PNG, I apologize.
Um, but I have some work that I need to get done.
That's why I brought my laptop in the first place and my whole setup.
But as you can see, it's a little scuffed.
like oh so also i had bought a smaller version of my inter interface that i use at the maid cafe to be my travel interface this is previously and then i used it at an event and it completely like shat itself it was it was uh like i guess it's made more for i don't i thought i was using it correctly but I guess it's made more for um like musical like playing playing like if you're recording guitar and stuff and uh I figured I was like you know if I ever do a collab like on its own it was totally fine if I was doing a collab or something it would like double the audio and things like that so I was like okay well I'll get I'll get rid of it and then um I bought the Which I have not had a GoXLR in an extremely long time.
Yeah, it was really awful.
I used it at MGSCon.
And it was, you know, I thought I had the correct settings.
But there literally was no other settings that I could try.
So I was like, oh, I felt so terrible.
Because, you know, I was like, I thought it was the same.
same as my interface at home but it just didn't have enough channels of how i do my setup um didn't go xlr die i yes but also they were like bought out question mark or something what do i usually use i use i normally use a yamaha ag08 and then they have the yamaha ag03 which is what i had bought and i was like this is perfect it's exactly my setup i know i like it I know I like,
I know how to use it, except it just doesn't work for my kind of streaming.
Like I said, it would be fine on its own.
It would just, you know, I don't want to get something.
And then if I'm traveling, you know, last time I traveled, I had a collab with like Kiara and Kobo and Ali.
So I was like, wait, wait, it was, wait.
Am I going crazy?
Olly was in that collab, right?
Or am I insane right now?
No?
Wait, who?
There was one other...
Wait, yes!
Yeah, okay, I was like...
Okay.
Because I remember, because I saw...
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I...
Okay, I remember why I was confused.
It's because I was thinking of Olly's default outfit.
But in the thumbnail, I used...
her like otaku outfit that's why i was like wait a second so um yeah so
and so um like you know i wouldn't have been able to do that collab if i had the other interface you know things like that i was like i don't want to say no to stuff just because of my interface so so i got the go xlr mini instead but right now right now it's giving me this error dcp error please update your firmware to the most recent version which i did it says if firmware is up to date try repairing the driver with our driver repair wizard and i just really don't feel like doing that and it won't let me into the software to edit anything like my voice or the the or the noise gate so it might sound a little strange i apologize this is everything is just so scoffed i hope my phone's okay being hot spot i pay per gig so um uh yeah i pay i pay per gig so I wonder what we're at.
Oh my god, I'm watching the number go up.
Guys, I might be cooked.
How much do you pay per gig?
Err.
$10?
But it caps.
It caps.
It caps, it caps.
Google 5 caps at $80.
Quick.
Turn off the video.
Here's a kick.
Thank you.
No, no, no, no.
I'm just gonna get rid of the number and not think about it.
we're just not going to think about it everybody because because i'm i wanted to be here and so that's why i made it happen because i thank you guys thank you because i you know it's i've been gone for a couple of days and i wanted to say hi and things have happened if you didn't catch the twitter space and you're like what the heck is this debut uh waiting room and what the heck is this that is looping and densetsu dot exe what is this so the the short version is the group that I was going to debut with we decided to move forward with it we're having some help backing but we are still indie um we're not corpo or anything i just have a manager now which is kind of nice but um it's just the three of us we're just gonna do our best and try and do cool things together and that's that's that's it um things are still gonna be pretty same for like all the content that i do and um uh so just probably more like you know hopefully more shows hopefully more uh opportunities um so yeah it's
steiner managing the three of us steiner is a phoebe's manager he's been managing her um he's been very nice and very helpful.
But, uh, underground idol group.
That is probably the best way to put it.
It's like an underground idol group.
Is it actually just Steiner?
We do have a small team.
But, like, Steiner is, like, our main manager.
So, which is kind of insane.
That, like, you know.
I've had people be like, yeah, I used to read his blogs.
It's like, Can you tell Steiner we said he's cute?
Um, sure.
Steiner's a legendary localizer.
I know, it's crazy, right?
So, are you guys going to game together too?
We will!
Just, you know, look forward to the three of us.
You know, we'll be collabing more together.
It's just us being fun gals.
So you can look forward to girls being cute girls.
as always and and a big deal is uh people you might be wondering why are they all silhouettes well one we don't want to show you the cute key visual art yet but also two vicky will be debuting completely new she is she is it's her actual debut so you know i'm the less important one here so victoria roman debut this coming friday I know,
finally!
And also, there might be some other surprises.
And we might, you know, we've been working on some cool stuff for you guys.
And of course the song.
Very, very excited for the song.
So, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
For me, it's, you know, it says debut, but it's really just a way to kind of...
You know, it'd be, I feel like we've, I felt like it would be kind of awkward to, how do you say, every, the other two debut, but not me, you know, I'm already, I'm already just doing my thing.
Um, but, so it's more like a, like an introduction to, to Minto, reintroduction.
Yeah, so it's, it is a group debut because we are, you know, solidifying our name together.
there and the hall.
Chicaido!
Happy birthday!
Happy birthday with salutations!
May your sky stay blue!
Happy birthday to you!
Woo!
I'm sorry.
Solidifying?
Minto Gear Solid?
Bum.
Yes.
Minto Gear Solid.
Always.
Congratulations on the big news.
Minto, I'm super happy for you, Victoria and Phoebe.
Thank you.
Support you in everything you do.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's all pretty much, everything's pretty much staying the same.
Just a little bit of extra support in the back end and a little, maybe a little shiny.
I have maybe some new updated updated things so yeah it'll still be it'll still feel a little bit new but also the same so
So the dot exe is pronounced dot exe Oh, well you can say the dot or you don't have to say the dot just remember the dot is there Den set to exe a dot exe it's pronounced like dot ink
love exe cover one right
ecuzee ecuzee what does densets mean Densetsu means legend in Nihongo in Japanese we have a bit of a you'll see on the debut it's a little bit of a backstory so yeah yeah legend
like umapyoidensu Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Will you be singing Make You Kiyun Kiyun Kiyun Friday night together?
We could?
I have to...
I guess maybe.
Hot spot funds.
More like hot pot funds.
Hey, oh, my gosh, you guys.
Dinner today.
Went to three different places.
And all of them were an hour wait.
I was like Oh my god An hour wait And then finally we went to I'm hanging out with friends That's why I say we But Finally we get to a restaurant And they're serving us And they're like By the way All of our stuff has been coming out 30 minutes late
What did you guys end up having?
We had ramen Ramen ramen ramen It was pretty tasty Okay it was good but man i just i just don't go out enough so i didn't think you know none of us thought about making a reservation because we don't go out to places typically and also i don't if i do go out to a place i'm either one like getting takeout or two i am i am not i am not there's not this
Coincidentally, reading a manga about an underground underground idol group.
Let me make your announcement.
Wait, which one?
Camp intro.
Thank you so much for the pink.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you.
Just make hot pot.
Yeah, if my hotel room had a stove.
Maybe.
Hello, Minto from Japan!
Ducky!
I hope you're having fun.
I hope you had a good weekend weekend.
You too, guys.
Oh, what's been up?
What's going on?
Wait, I should start working on work, huh?
Instead, because we haven't talked in a couple days.
That's why I just go to Cocoa Echi or Pepper Lunch.
Well, if I was in Japan, I would go to Cocoa Echi or Pepper Lunch.
I'm not in Japan, you guys.
is not good day minto i recently discovered you're single and i've taken to listening to it before work shift and it makes me happy oh is this what being an idol fan is like oh my gosh thank you what like welcome to mint cafe that's all
mint not in japan i know crazy I'm traveling and I'm not in Japan?
Who raised it?
I know!
My Asayoru collab got sold out!
I'm, I'm, I'm shocked.
I'm like, I think, I think I was told that there was concern about me selling out, so...
Or not me, but like, but like, you know, the event's selling out, so...
Oh no!
You gotta take a thank you!
Dame dollu to the world?
Wait, one?
One?
One only fan?
Or the useless idol and her only fan in the world?
Oh, that sounds so cute!
Sell out, convert.
Oh yeah, I'm a sell out.
I'm selling out!
out heard of that one
gone corporate me yeah i'm a corporate shill yeah that oh well life i'm returning back i'm that's that's gonna be my debut is returning to being an office lady she's gone corporate she's back in the office
She's...
When they say she's gone corporate, it's real!
It's real!
The cubicle calls.
No, no, no, no, please.
No, please, God.
No.
God, no.
Please, God.
I'm Michaeling.
I'm Michael Scotting right now.
God, no, please.
Please don't make me go back to the cubicle.
I'll be a good ghost.
I promise.
Though I have thought about, like, you know, if I were to get another job.
You know, because I could just work in the morning and then stream at night.
That's what I used to do.
So it's nothing that I couldn't.
Whoa, hi, Minto.
Working on debut stuff.
Yes.
yes i'm supposed to be working on debut stuff
would you ever even want to i have multiple thoughts about it one of them is like so i'm the kind of i'm the type that like even if i won the lottery i would still want to keep a stable job because i you know i've like to have a key i like to keep my work ethic in a in a way like i like to stay busy i like to i like i don't you know if i'm not working i i i don't feel i i don't know like it's just yeah i think it keeps you sane for real right job gives you structure right right so there's that and then also like you know the it's it's you know i i i rely very much on the generosity of you guys to literally do anything and so to me you know if if i could lesson that for you guys and just be funny you know gush girl or like uh how to say um you know have something to kind of you know keep things feeling stable obviously everybody is there's there's many oh you guys are so generous and kind to me and i i i uh don't feel i deserve it and so i you know know,
I, um, you know, just that, just me being like, hmm, you know, what if, what if I had another job and then I could like turn off super chats or something, something like that, you know what I mean?
So, so yeah, just so that, you know, it's less, it's more, or rather it's more like a,
The vibes.
Here for the vibes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Obviously, I do appreciate each and every one of you.
So, thank you very much.
And if you want to support me, I, of course, appreciate that so much.
And if you're just here to watch, I, of course, appreciate that so much as well.
So, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
What a late stream.
It is really late, right?
that is quite late I apologize but of course please sleep if you need to sleep or if you're up late working with me that is not good go to sleep about 1 a .m.
4 a.m.
3 a.m.
oh my goodness You are the funniest.
I'm fine.
Hi, P.C.
Hello.
Dusty Dog.
Thank you so much for the five gift.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you guys for the super chats.
And welcome back to membership.
The noise gate on this is kind of insane.
Wait, I think it's because...
My computer is loud.
Can you hear this?
It's so loud.
Oh, my God.
I'm, like, close to the van right now.
And it's so loud.
sounded like a creeper breathing wait like what kind of creeper like a minecraft creeper or what do we what do we what do we or like a kind of creeper you don't hear the fan at all oh that's great did you hear that that was the fan hold on Whoa.
Churn.
That's audible.
Yeah, here I'll do it again.
Wait, it's kind of like, it kind of gives me like ocean vibes, right?
Like you hear the ocean and it's kind of, it's kind of soothing, right?
Yeah.
It's like old TV white noise.
Yeah, this is pretty good.
This is pretty good.
Wait, should I just, when I am working on stuff, which I totally will do.
Should I just hold the mic up to the fan?
Huh.
It's not working now.
Okay.
Authentic office vibe?
No, no, no.
That would be like if I had like my boss coming up and being like, Hey, Minto, you got that paperwork done for me yet?
That would be like, oh my God, please.
No, I'm working on it.
Is that what we sound like because we are fans?
I think you guys sound nicer, probably.
10 out of 10 boss voice.
Hey, Minto, is that paperwork done yet?
What is a TPS?
What is that?
Wait, TPS.
T?
Well,
it's from Office Space.
What's Office Space?
What is Office Space?
Is that a game or a movie or a show or...
It's a great movie.
No, I've never seen office.
Hold on.
Where's my phone?
Oh, right here.
Don't look at the numbers.
What am I at even?
I'm so curious.
I want to look at the numbers.
Number go up.
Office space.
Movie, you guys said?
Oh, it's old.
What is this description?
Corporate drone Peter Gibbons hates his soul-killing job at software company Initech.
While undergoing hypnotherapy, Peter is left in a blissful space when his therapist dies in the middle of their session.
He refuses to work overtime, plays.
games at his desk and unintentionally charms two consultants into putting him on the management fast track.
When Peter's friends learn they're about to be downsized, they hatch a revenge plot against the company inspired by Superman 3.
What does that mean?
Stop reading?
Wait, why?
It sounds funny.
that's a good movie oh spoilers well i don't understand what it what it means it was just a small overview there's this one office boss in office space that's your typical yeah so we're gonna need you to write those tps reports after hours thanks a lot and then he sips coffee okay it's just a bit spoiler it's okay i i don't understand it so i don't think I got spoiled at all because I've never seen Superman 3 so I've never seen Superman 3 I'm safe I'm safe
movie name office space
guys I'm so sleepy listen it was directed by the creator of King of the Hill Oh!
It's probably pretty good.
I am a yonder.
I'm sorry.
It's really funny.
Def recommend for the former office gal.
I've worked several offices.
Actually, I'd say three?
And then, no, four.
Four offices not four office jobs in my afterlife uh i've had many jobs i literally okay guys i don't know if i've ever said this before either but like one time i got a job at a japanese company and um i literally did that thing where the whole almost the entire interview was in japanese and but it was a japanese company in the United States.
I literally did that thing where it's like when you, when you put your, your, when you, when you, when you put that you are Japanese, when you put, or like, you know, when you lie on your resume, I literally did that.
interview they asked me questions and then i answered something and it totally got them on another tangent because so basically i could not understand it all like i couldn't understand like the mechanical jargon that they used but then they asked me another question and i answered that and then and then they started talking a lot and and then the interview was over and they were like okay cool you got the job i did i maybe spoke like three words to this interview
Like, I literally was just probably like, Oh, hi.
So this, then they were like, You're hired.
Literally fake it till you make it.
But the job was kind of hell.
Oh, the entire.
Okay, so how do I explain?
I was like a middle.
I don't really understand what I got hired to do.
So, like, how do I explain?
Okay, how do I explain?
It was like, okay.
They kind of,
it was like shipping parts to shipping, like, machine parts to other companies is like the best way.
that i can describe it and so my job the girl who trained me trained me for a week and then she was like i'm out see ya and it was like a logistics yes yes yeah my job though was to to make guesses on how long the things would take to arrive at the at the company and I was like how do you know and she would be like well you see there's a boat and it literally is just vibes guessing the
like i'd be like okay and apparently she was like the best she could guess things down to like a day or something she was so good she was a prodigy guesser like or something and me i was like well how do you know and she was like the boat comes and i'm like okay but like yeah and she's feel it and i'm like what and so then she left and i would be stuck there like
what am i doing and and um safe to say i i didn't last very long there was like a whole spreadsheet of boats and you would have to like look at like the longitude and the latitude of the boat and then be like okay this is where the boat is at and then guess and then fill out the spreadsheet of like of like this is this is how long it will take before it's there and you had people every day And she would just,
the girl training me, she would be like, oh yeah, like Kumiko-sama, she's crazy.
She will message you, she will email you every day asking how much longer.
And I just subtracted a day because it's the next day.
So if it's 30 days, the next day that she emails you, you say 29.
it just works that was that was a job that i had you guys like a real job that was a real job
oh geez and they would get really mad at you if your if your predictions were not correct about how long it would take for these things to arrive.
I feel like they trolled you or something.
It was very...
I... It was...
It was very... It was a very strange job.
I wasn't as good as the girl that trained me.
She was a prodigy guesser.
She could just...
She, like, sensed it in her little brain.
She had, like, antenna coming out of her head that could communicate with the boat i heard fake it till you make it but never fake it till you fake some more it's uh yeah yeah
office might be like hi so i guess like japanese was not like a super requirement but they would talk to me in in japanese and i'm like i'm i'm i'm literally slaving away at my desk literally measuring latitude and longitude of these boats and they're like konnichiwa minto san
I'm like down to like millimeters maybe their question was hmm yeah she looks like a kankole fan you can sense the boat yeah they thought I had boat sense but the great part was it was uh it was pretty close to the old maid cafe that I was haunting so um so yeah it was uh i i i yeah i was pretty close and then it was it was a job yeah it was a job and i needed one yeah yeah and i remember i had that job and i remember applying for other jobs being like this i can't i am not a boat psychic i can't do this i don't understand i'm not the boat whisperer and so i was like putting in other job and i remember i got a i finally had gotten a job uh at another place that was like over an hour away and i took it because It was over an hour one way of a commute.
And so I took that because that's how desperate I was to get away from the boats.
I was desperate.
Oh, great meantle of the boat.
What is my numbers to win the lottery?
Give me your longitude and latitude right now.
And I got you, buddy.
I got you.
Out of morbid curiosity, how much did this job pay?
Great question.
I can't remember.
but i believe it was like 13 14 an hour
yeah um yeah
hmm yeah
so full time full time full time
still think it's badass that you are hired with only three words.
Thank you.
13 an hour in the 80s.
Whoa!
The coordinates!
I wonder where that shows.
The 1800s.
Hey, how old do you think I am?
There were no mid-couple is in the 1800s only real maids oh my gosh jay herchin thank you this was 20 minutes ago but thank you so much for the akadono just got back from my first japan trip thank you for all your recommendations jam is probably my favorite maid cafe so far and i will go back again this is extra cash i managed to save from the claw machines thank you daily dayo thank you speaking of going corporate i'm being onboarded as a video editor at a big company thanks in part to so much practice editing minto clips oh nice good job to learn mint was once an office lady is pretty appealing to me i love office lady aesthetic i've yeah i've been office lady a couple times yeah yeah yeah yeah so but I prefer maid I don't want to be I don't want an OL outfit you guys I don't want to be reminded please you can draw fan art though just don't want to think about me being an office lady please please don't make me do it
I didn't say Don't say that she wanted to get an office job again Oh, and I didn't I don't think I said that I want an office job per se I was thinking a job in general Not just an office job Something I don't know Who knows I might be too busy though We'll see Minto wanted to be a grocer I'm gonna bag your grocer wouldn't that be kind of nice though from bagging your groceries and I'm like how are you doing today when you're like good and I'm like wow you sure are buying a lot of cheese just shift the eyes then you'd be like you'd never come back I'd be like,
hmm, someone's hungry.
It's for a party.
Yeah.
You would never come back.
She's so good at small talk.
I know.
Yeah, what's my total?
if you say you're having a party I'd be like can I be can I come over am I invited what are you making with all the cheese just put the cheese in the bag man put the cheese in the bag put it in the bag have you done retail before I have yep I've done I've done retail before um um I quit right before I went on vacation because they didn't approve it.
It was like a Christmas, you know, around Christmas.
And I was going, I had already planned my trip.
And they were like, nah, that's Christmas.
And I was like, okay, bye.
But right before I quit, right before I left, my boss had actually, he got fired by corporate because he was stealing money from the safe they caught him so um things were a little topsy-turvy anyway uh i got out yeah so you know it's a good thing you aren't office worker because we get to be here with you yeah please input the barcode numbers into the computer's manually oh i had that as a job actually um where uh i worked for a car insurance company that was another office job that i did but i manually input every single carvin into the system yeah that was my job yeah data entry yep that was when it was that job that i uh what's the word it was that would listen to like audiobooks and so that's when i started like listening to the really strange ones like the billionaire boys club and i think i think also on that job i like yeah minotaur milking farm no that was that was just recreational but yeah it was at my data entry job that i started listening to audiobooks
So...
Enzo Mancini!
I once had a job where my manager was blatantly stealing money from the safe on camera without even thinking.
Without even trying to hide it.
Not sure what he was thinking.
Yeah.
I wish I had such a storied history.
Really?
I don't know.
I've just had a lot of jobs.
You know, uh, for as long as I can remember, you know, how to pay for my own stuff.
So, always, always working.
I'm just trying to get one.
You can do it.
I know that it can be really tough, especially with like how I've heard, sorry, oh my gosh, I just really, like we're talking about the j-word that's so scary we're talking about jobs but you know um but uh what's the word you they're like things right now are like so difficult because like offices will put up like ghost positions or they'll like filter through certain words or stuff like that.
It's kind of strange.
It's like a strange time to apply for jobs.
So, you know, don't be so hard on yourself if it's really tough, you know.
Hmm.
You know, a lot of people are having a lot of trouble.
So it's not just you.
It's not just you.
You got this.
Mm-hmm.
So many fake listings, too.
Yeah, I'm like, why?
I also had a data entry job plumbing equipment for an aquaculture business.
I would also have to take the mail to the mailbox, which was down a long dirt road.
I would race the company dog off foot.
What?
That sounds awesome.
if i buy a membership is it going to renew every month um it does it does renew every month but thank you i appreciate you with the super chat and even considering the villainous dance thank you so much for that gift and thank you thank you for the double dip double double double double-gifted.
Thank you.
Remember there was a fake post office jobs in my area.
No!
Double, double, double, double, double.
Double, double, double.
Double, double gifting.
Double dipping.
Don't double dip.
That's nasty.
You gotta be sanitary.
Okay.
Guys, I didn't get any work done.
I just have too much fun talking to you guys.
I just have so much fun.
I missed you guys.
I'll try to stream tomorrow as well.
Productive evening.
We're catching up.
Can we catch a little?
out well thank you though you know for very impromptu uh the impromptu stream and uh what's the lord just you know hanging out with me i really appreciate it i miss you guys but i'll be back oh well i'll see i might i'll see you tomorrow and then also stuff this week,
debut.
Densetsu.exe.
And...
Yeah!
Thank you.
I hope you guys have a good rest.
us too what is the debut anyway you're already here oh i explained it at the beginning of the stream but i'll say it again um basically because vicky and febe are debuting i am awesome it would be kind of weird for only the two of them we're kind of like just doing it as like a formality it's really just to be like look at us you know we're we're a group now we're group together
It's kind of like, you know, just like an introduction to me.
So, yeah.
Showing camaraderie.
So,
new model.
If only.
The debut was supposed to happen so long ago that I was...
supposed to debut my second outfit at it like that's how long ago it was supposed to happen
so yeah
but it's okay everything i feel i feel we're you know we're just we're just chilling i mean we're not chilling we're we are working hard but almost feels like we're chilling just because it's like you know we have had a lot of time to hang out and get to know each other and we're just we're just all goofy together so to me it almost feels like chilling because i'm like i'm feeling like relaxed with them because they're my friends so
Maybe I'm just also feeling relaxed in the moment because I'm sleepy.
So I'm like, you know, I'm very excited, but I'm also like, yeah, he's cute.
He's cute.
Yeah, I'm vibing.
Yeah, so that hopefully, if that didn't explain it completely, you can listen at the beginning of the stream fun times ahead so hope you're still having fun even though it's work i'm having so much fun can't wait for you guys to see the work that is happening at the very moment but i always still feel bad that like i've been talking to other people about it recently just
gone for when i when i leave for when i have to like you know leave my maid cafe to go do work outside like the guilt is that you know i can't stream i'm working but i can't stream so it feels like i'm not working and so it's it's like a it's like a weird you know obviously like i'm doing stuff but you won't see it for like a long time from now so oh my gosh unreal citizen thank you so much
so it's like a strange feeling how like it's like you know i'm doing stuff but it's not streaming for me streaming always remains my number one priority and that will continue you know that's laptop when I'm traveling and things like that so even if it's like a little one hour yapping session it still is you know just something to you know talk to you guys say hi give you company if you want a background stream or anything like that so that's why I'm very let's you know it's not everybody's mindset but it's definitely my mindset
yeah yeah yes yes yes the stream refreshed me fully really talk about logistics and cheese
but also I've talked about this with people too I feel like especially to do these kinds of yapping sessions like back when I did have my office job i would go out and i would do things and i would have stories to talk about you know it's like i can only tell my my five-year-old story so many times before you know obviously there's always going to be someone new in chat that's never heard a story before but you know there's there's only so many times i can reuse these old stories so i have to go out and and experience things so that i eyes and talk to you about you know what i mean so it's it's a bit of a balance it's a bit of a balance it's kind of like a strange thing that you know i'm also thinking about
new hauntings exactly why do you always have to stream when i'm sleeping i'm sorry that's just that's just my schedule
gotta go live your life but I'm not living what do I I gotta go experience what it would feel like to be living
live your afterlife yeah yeah
you gotta go after live exactly just a little bit sometimes but that's also sometimes why i play so many games and don't do very many like talking streams is because i'm like oh gosh sometimes i'm you know i'm like what what what if i what if i run out of things to talk about i don't know when i play game i can talk about game
i now curse you with what did you curse me with with an interesting afterlife no
saving up stories for the winter like nuts oh my gosh i saw a fat squirrel that guy was huge i'll be like i also saw a squirrel that was in a trash can and he was like poking his head out and eating from the trash can.
And I was like, you think you're you think you're the king of this place?
Get out of there.
Squail.
Squail mentioned.
I don't know what it is.
I think those guys are funny.
Okay.
Good night, Minto.
Thanks for the stream.
Good night.
Can you say Jaguar?
Why?
Get a job as a chicken nugget expert.
Now, what makes an expert on chicken nuggets?
The first thing that popped into my head was like, Finding chicken nuggets that resemble shapes of things.
You know, like, I could be an expert and say, like, this chicken nugget definitely looks like a picture of Michael Jackson.
And people would look at it and be like, I see Michael Jackson.
Abraham Lincoln Yes
Yes Oh my gosh That would be like a fun museum Going to a museum of preserved foods That look like Things or people But like Not like a dino nuggy that is Shaped into it But like They just took it out of the bag And bam bam Thank you ma'am That is That's Keanu Reeves.
Jesus on toast.
The Museum of Jesus toasts.
Where would they source these from?
They're all donations.
Donate to your local arts.
We're a museum.
I'm starting this right now.
If you have ever had a food item that looks like something, Give it to me right now.
So I can preserve it in its best state.
And then display it in my museum of oddities.
Of chicken nugget shapes.
And other food items.
Chicken nugget shapes that look like people or things.
That's the name of my museum.
haunted jesus toast would be a museum of haunted jesus toast do you not remember that each chicken mcnugget had an avatar that represented them what i have no idea what you're talking about what is that
pizza with pineapple we can't we not just i mean we're not just we didn't just put pizza with pineapple in the museum we have standards cheetos shaped like a dragon thank you yes we Please donate.
Please send it to me right now.
Please send me your Cheeto in the shape of a dragon.
That will be our...
Our monthly...
Main exhibit.
In fact?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, hold on.
What if...
What if you found...
how many are there of those stone warrior statues what are they called the terracotta the terracotta's army the terracotta soldiers what if you found like what if you found like a hundred cheetos that looked like what you found 100 individual cheetos that looked like wait and each one looked like a terracotta soldier and then you displayed them that's that's just as interesting as going to the real thing no in fact i would say it's maybe more impressive because you would have to dig through hundreds of cheetos to find enough to create a terracotta army replica army next cam stream i i open i open 1 000 bags of cheetos looking for one that looks like one terracotta army soldier
the chance is not zero exactly and that's why that's why why it's going to be my mission.
I'm going to become a Terracotta Army Soldier Cheeto Soldier Finding YouTube account.
This is actually what my new debut is.
I'm rebranding.
The reason why it's a silhouette is because literally my new model is a Cheeto.
my whole new look cheeto i look like a like a gosh darn cheesy puff
rebranding stream need to get some sleep now i'm going to the Gundam base early tomorrow good night me to have fun have fun your boat guessing job amplified your psychic guessing powers you've got this thank you no well thank you so much for the pink patrick oh boy 4 a.m time for some minto drop to say hi i'm back to sleep good night mint would you accept this potato chip i just found like haley joel osman nope well and everyone says i have terrible ideas hui shut up i guess i have to accept anything But anything that resembles Haley Joel Osmond would go...
Okay, you know how Zach Baggins has his Museum of Haunted Things?
And it's like you have to sign a waiver to go in and you have to like, you know, spooky things might happen to you?
That's the same exact thing.
If you were to view...
It's like, okay, it's like you see the Haley Joel Osmond chip.
Potato chip?
it might be like the movie from the ring and you might have seven days and you might die after you look at it it's literally just basement exhibit room for haley jasmine food
it might it might just be like an actual cursed object the haley jelazment cheeto is a biohazard Yes.
Literally, to even handle it, I need to be in a hazmat suit.
Special glasses.
Haley Jalazmint Cheeto Potato Chip would belong.
That would just be an SCP.
What did he do to you to be cursed?
Well, his face is just a little too small for his big fat head.
And it makes me really uncomfortable.
And that's why I don't like him.
That's about it.
I do remember you saying that before.
He can't help it, give him a second chance.
You're streaming with Hotspot?
Oh yeah, let me see what the number is up to.
Oh, it's actually less than I thought.
thought.
I'm almost at 13 gigs.
That's not so bad.
I started at 2.
So I've streamed about 11 gigs in an hour.
Yeah, actually it's not so bad.
I thought it was going to be like at 80 or something crazy.
Nice.
How hot is my phone?
Not even.
She's spicy.
Expensive stream.
Yeah.
The things I do for love.
But I am really tired now.
It's almost midnight.
So I'm gonna...
I have to get ready for bed.
And I have to wake up early tomorrow.
Ah!
More stuff to...
do but thank you guys for this fun time letting me in chit chat with you all and everything yeah
um hopefully i could stream again tomorrow and dorko thank you so much for the pink thank you if you dream of goat heads dream of them as office stooges Yeah.
But thanks for hanging out with me for a little bit.
It was quite nice.
And I will talk to you guys.
I'm going to talk to you next.
Yeah.
Latuminto, everybody.
Hopefully this was relaxing enough.
So that you could, like, listen to it.
And feel chill.
You know?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, one second.
Oh, there we go.
Latuminto, everybody.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, I will see you when I see you next.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Eat the next time.
Bye-bye.